welcome back to the beginner to Master
speedrun episode number 25 we do have a
change of scenery today I'm in Bali
Indonesia escaping the cold winter from
the US uh nice tropical climate here and
coming into today rated
1251 on an 80 plus game win streak so
let's hop into
it first opponent playing GM
scri who doesn't have the official GM
title uh but rated just below 1300
and playing the King's Pawn as usual we
have a Petrov defense uh are we going to
see a Stafford Knight takes E5 and we do
see a Stafford Gambit okay so this is
the second Stafford Gambit I've
encountered so far this
speedrun and uh yeah there's a few moves
for white to attempt to refute this
opening uh always brings me pain to show
the reputation of the Stafford usually
the opening I like to to play and win
with from the black side but uh yeah
there's D3 and Knight C3 these are the
the two I think most practical moves
there's also E5 which is a bit more
aggressive um I'm going to play Knight
C3 last time I had played D3 which is
also completely acceptable and now in
this position it's really really
important to address Black's threats cuz
a lot of people will go wrong here with
Bishop C4 or D3 uh both of which which
are blunders cuz black is threatening
Knight G4 and uh yeah D3 or Bishop C4
don't really prevent Knight G4 so the
simplest move to play here is Pawn H3
and this just prevents Knight G4 and uh
yeah black is actually still following
my repertoire I also like to play Pawn
H5 and yeah H5 looks a little bit
nonsensical because I've already
prevented Knight G4 uh but there is an
idea that if white plays Bishop E2 then
black can play Queen D4 casting Knight
G4 and that's actually a winning line
for black so against
H5 um I'm just going to play solidly
I'll play Pawn to D3 and this prepares
to develop my darks for Bishop and very
often against the Stafford Gambit it can
be a good idea to KN Castle kingside
where black is ready to attack but
rather Castle Queen side um and
sometimes the king just stays in the
center while my Bishops and queen
develop so we'll see what black comes up
with here but uh yeah I'm going to try
and show no mercy to this opening um I
mean black can still try and get a
playable
position Bishop G4 highly aggressive uh
I don't think I've ever seen this move
before it's interesting but yeah I'm
just going to take the bishop the pawn
can't take because it's pinned after
Knight takes okay black sack a piece to
get some attack against
F2 now the main move I'm considering
here is actually to give away my queen
with Queen takes G4 this is a very
forcing line because if the pawn were to
take I can win The Rook skewer Black's
king and queen win back the queen and
simplify completely
so just going to double check to make
sure not missing anything like the main
move I have to be aware of is Bishop
takes F2 and after King takes F2 there
is Queen
D4 but then they have Bishop E3 to
counter attack yeah that looks
completely fine oh no my queen a very
temporary Queen
sacrifice oh
actually oh no I'm not winning back the
queen oh I completely missed Bishop
f8 oops well thankfully I did win some
material I won a knight and a rook and I
also won the Knight previously on G4 so
I I have enough material for not having
a
queen uh what is it I have Bishop
Knight and Rook for
Queen so everything is still under
control uh that was a slightly
embarrassing oversight though missing
the the backwards bishop move sometimes
these these retreating moves are the the
easiest moves to
overlook um thankfully okay life is
still fine I'm now threatening Bishop to
C5 also preparing Queen side
castling but black does have a playable
position like it's still going to take a
lot of work to try and win from here
Queen
F6 uh can I just play Bishop C5 right
away I always have to be careful putting
a piece on an undefended
Square also second guessing myself uh
given I overlooked one of the previous
moves but this looks fine and I don't
see a great way for roock to defend the
bishop your queen side castling will
just
take and win more
material black could play G6 to attack
The Rook but then I'll win the bishop
and then win the The Rook on
A8 yeah so we're going to see an example
of when having a queen is just not
enough because from the white side I
just have so many pieces for it I'll
take the bishop with my Rook which will
force a rook
trade and after takes takes my Bishop is
on a weird Square on f8 but I don't
think it's getting trapped Bishop will
have the diagonal to
retreat so weird game to start the
episode yeah I guess we we see the
trickiness of of the Stafford like even
even though my opponent played what
should have been a bad line I kind of uh
made some oversight making it not super
simple so Queen G5 uh logical move
preventing me from casing Queens side
maybe preparing G3 as well this also
prevents Bishop C5 I would have liked to
play Bishop C5 and Bishop E3 to
centralize so what do I want to do maybe
just
G3 this prevents B from playing
G3 and I do have time here to try and
organize my pieces try and find the
optimal setup I think at some point I
will Retreat probably all the way back
to
A3 and what I might end up doing is like
playing Bishop G2 and King
E2 I don't see a great way to try and
prepare Queens side
castling and the long-term plan is
probably to get the Rook to
H1 and then gradually optimizing my
minor
pieces black putting on the pressure
Pawn
F5 this does give me the chance to play
Bishop
C5 and then if takes I can take and
defend and
attack although Bishop C5 could walk
into F4 which looks a little bit
annoying so trying to find the
simplest reply
here Bishop
[Music]
G2 I mean F4 is coming I could
take maybe taking is uh the way to go
and then if Queen takes I think I can
get away with taking on
G7 it's always scary having an
undefended piece this case very deep in
my opponent's
territory but yeah there there's no like
double attack Queen E7 is not
possible and queen E6 I can you can
block with a knight or with a
bishop so I am getting a little a little
bit uh antsy to get my Rook into play
been moving around this bishop a lot but
so far it's working
out and now if I queen side Castle I
give away
F2 so I'm going to start with Knight E4
really nice centralizing move over
defending
F2 and yeah there's no black pawn that
can chase away my knight from E4 so this
is now a really solid
Construction and very soon I'll look to
Castle and then try and start organizing
my
pieces and yeah it's hard for black to
like generate too many threats here
maybe one thing black could try is Queen
F3 preventing me from castling and if I
play Bishop E2 there' be Queen
H1 so yeah Queen F3 is probably the most
annoying
move and black could also try to pawn
storm but it's not really the scariest
of
storms okay so Queen F7 attacking the
bishop let's
Retreat I should note that my Rook is
now tied down to A2 so I might have to
play another Preparatory move before
actually
castling but trying to be patient here
uh this looks like a free Pawn yeah
let's take it
and this bishop has moved so many times
this game but I think most of the moves
have been pretty well
Justified okay Queen is
attacking my B2 Pawn so I think it's
time to Castle and
defend and maybe pretty soon I can start
thinking about some mating attack like
having three minor pieces and a rook
assuming I can coordinate them like if I
get a knight to C5 Pawn to D4 get the
lights squ Bishop
in I mean hopefully I can pretty quickly
start strangling the the black
king playing Bishop D2 to get the bishop
to a better Central
Square and this bishop has really gone
on a journey got developed to E3 and
then C5 and then f8 and then back and
then I already forget the ex exact path
somehow I got to C3 took and now the
bishop has come to
F4 and everything is defended in this
position um except my A2 Pawn which is
no longer
attacked so let's develop go after the
pawn on
G4 Queen h8 this is tricky cuz now if I
take the pawn there's Queen G8 with a
double attack against my bishop and my
A2
Pawn
so yeah even when the position looks
very fine still always want to be a
little bit
careful um I'm going to start with
Knight C5 really like the square for the
Knight D4 likely to come or maybe if
King B6 I can play Bishop E3 first
aligning with the
King I'm trying to conceptualize like
some mating idea it already feels close
King
A5 my problem is if I move the Knight
allows King
A6 so I'm going to start with Pawn
D4 cementing the Knight also preparing
to lift the
rook and actually if I get the Rook to
A3 then it'll be Force checkmates
because King B6 Rook A6
checkmates nice mating idea the pawn
supporting the Knight supporting The
Rook check mating the king
okay black is attacking the
Apon so there's a a famous Ben Fold
saying now anybody who is my student or
has listened to my lectures and has less
brain damage than most of you at home
remembers my rule always
play King B1 very good always play King
B1 it's very typical when you Castle
Queens side to slide the king over of
course it's a very late stage in the
game I probably could have played Rook
D3 to set up Queen A2 and Rook A3 but
yeah really giving back no chances
here
and yeah Pawn
B4 okay I do have to watch out for
potential stalemate
traps yeah let's be very careful I mean
this Pawn can legally move and pawn B4
prevents a rook A3
idea so what's the best way to do this
maybe still Rook D3 and then I'll look
to play
A3 and get rid of this
Pawn Yeah like for
example there are potential lines where
I could stumble into stalemates like
Queen Jak's A2 King takes A2 B3 Rook
takes B3 would be
stalemate so I do have to watch out like
if I strangle the king too much it could
backfire but okay the King has a B6
Square now black wants to play Queen
H1 uh I'm going to play
A3 making
Loof and also trying to get rid of the
pawn to eventually
Checkmate and when I say make Loof I
believe Luft is German for air basically
making an air bubble for my
king
and yeah that way there are um there
there's no mating attack for black I
could have also
blocked okay now Rook
B3 looks
fine and if Pawn takes Pawn then Bishop
D2 is
checkmates so you might see a somewhat
exotic Checkmate to finish this
game I do want to say though like big
hudos to my opponent for really putting
up a fight F like this is not the the
traditional way of trying to refute the
Stafford uh okay Queen F5
so yeah if I take with Pawn
there's uh there's King
B6 I mean there's probably a lot of ways
to win
here looking at Knight B7 check I'm
going to start with Bishop
D3 being patient not conceding the C2
on and I do really have to watch out for
stalemate
like there are a lot of lines where
uh for example if I take on B4 then the
king is still M and then back can try
and Sack the
queen um but now my Rook is
pinned okay so let's just
take forcing the king back to B6
and now we'll play
C4 which essentially unpins The
Rook although now I'm realizing Rook A3
walks into Queen takes
C4 and if I take back it's stal Mage
so opponent resigns but they they could
have really tried to fight
on um I think there's a lot of players
at this
level that would just stumble into a
stalemate tra like for example if black
just Waits uh Rook A3 looks like the
natural move I don't think I would have
played this because Queen takes
C4 and it's just a crazy stalemate black
has no legal moves all the pawns are
stuck and uh yeah the king is completely
restricted so maybe an important lesson
towards the end there is to uh to don't
resign prematurely like there's always
always the last stal
Matrix but uh very interesting game
um yeah in hindsight
maybe maybe I should not have taken on
G4 although it is a little bit annoying
to defend
F2 so perhaps Queen takes G4 was a a
very fine move but if I play this move
next time I should of course see Bishop
f8 um I'm just checking with the engine
here if there is a better
move although the engine is not working
been having some issues with getting
engine to work recently so that's okay
um hopefully some some opening lessons
and some later stage lessons to take
away from this game uh let's move on to
the next one was a long first game to
start the episode next opponent playing
mate2 and I'm not going to play as
Stafford um it's been a a goal in the
speedrun to to play more more solid more
reputable
openings so we're going to have a Four
Knights
here Four Knights is very very common at
the lower levels sometimes will come up
at the grandmas level as well Bishop B5
is one of the the main
lines uh I'm going to play Bishop
B4 against this line it's actually very
fine to copy White's
moves and there's a few different
approaches for white I mean castling and
D3 are probably the most
common I'm not scared of takes and takes
and takes cuz then there will be ways to
um to win back the pawn I wonder if we
will see Knight takes
E5 yeah if Knight takes E5 I probably
would have played Queen E7 and then very
likely win back the pawn on
e4 but now with D3 white might be
threatening to take on E5
so do have to be a little bit careful
here uh Queen E7 I think is very logical
just to support the
pawn and Bishop D6 was another option
but I like maintaining the pin and it's
possible later on that my Bishop will
come back to C5 where it's a bit more
centralized so going forward from here
um guess I do have a a choice like I
could Castle right away and then we have
a more positional game but what I can
also do is delay castling King side and
play Bishop G4
first and then maybe Castle Queen side
and have a more attacking
game so I like the idea of staying
flexible here not committing the king
just completing
development and now it's this Knight
that's pinned to Black's
Queen it's not so easy easy to resolve
the
pin cuz H3 I just go back and white
really doesn't want to play
G4 pushing the pawns where the king is
already
castled so Bishop D2 okay solid
move yeah very soon I'll have to make a
choice like if I Castle Queen side
then white will want to try and attack
on the queen side I want to try and
attack on the king side
but I think I have more attacking
potential than white so I'll go for
this one point I want to make is when
White's played
H3 the prospect of G5 and G4 becomes a
lot more dangerous because then I would
be forcibly opening up the G file of
course I have to deal with my Bishop
being
attacked
and yeah I think I'll I'll just Retreat
Bishop C5 aligning with the King
this does allow B4 or Knight
A4 and I can decide what to do with a
bishop if B4 then maybe I play Bishop
D4 then creating a situation where both
Knights are
pinned so Knight A4 might be the best
approach here for white then if I play
Bishop D4 there's C3 and if I move back
white can
trade so if Knight A4 I might just go
back to D6 to avoid the trade but we'll
see what white
does we do see Knight
A4 I should note I'm not live streaming
so my opponent can't stream snipe and
hear what I'm saying unless they've
somehow uh miked up my my room but don't
think that's too likely so yeah let's
avoid the trade Play Bishop
D6 and knight's a little bit awkward
award on A4 although maybe there's a
plan of like B4 and C4 and just
expanding in Pawn storming Bishop E3
also very
[Music]
logical I don't think I need to defend
the a pawn though maybe it makes sense
just to throw in King
B8 yeah I might as
well it's similar to the rule I talked
about last game with the Ben Fold saying
always play King E1 but when you're
black you can uh always consider playing
King B8 same idea to defend the Pawn
King is a little bit less exploitable
towards the
edge um but C4 yeah that's a pretty good
move cuz this move is now a threat and
B4 is
coming
so there's a few ways I can deal with
this I could move the queen and give the
bishop a square to to move back I could
also play C5 but I think with Pawn C5
that would just allow white to keep
focusing on the queen side and then open
the B
file and generally I don't want to allow
files to open on the side I'm castled on
especially when it's opposite side
castling so I'm a bit more inclined here
to play Queen E3 or queen
D7 Queen E6 I should say queen
D7
let's go with Queen
E6 bit more centralizing if white wants
to play this I'll I'll just
Retreat and actually if C5 Bishop
E7 then I think I'll be threatening
Knight takes E4 nice having The Rook
aligned with White's
Queen and from White's perspective I
mean they' really like to get the queen
to start pressuring ing the queen side
but if the Queen ever leaves D1 or E2 to
defend the Knight then I'll be happy to
take double wh's pawns and then Rampage
on the king
side so Knight C3 logical
move and now I don't really have a great
Prospect to try and set up tactics with
Knight takes
E4 so I'm actually considering Pawn G 5
here which is a pawn sacrifice but it
would open the G
[Music]
file and in a position like this very
often you can prioritize peace activity
over material and I think it's well
worth sacrificing upon Pawn to open the
G file and start generating
threats uh White quickly takes the pawn
so I'll play Rook
G8 and now I am am I threatening Rook
takes G5 cuz white could take back and
Counterattack my queen I'm probably
threatening Bishop takes F3 different
move
order uh to remove the guard but white
takes on
F6 so I'm going to pause here because
the most obvious recapture is just Queen
takes F6 but I also have Queen takes
H3 U but then there's
G3 might get a little bit murky
calculating Rook takes G3 Pawn takes G3
Queen takes G3 King
H1 yeah I think it's just simpler to
take back the bishop and now I have just
a ton of pressure on the king side
threatening very simply Bishop takes
F3 G Pawn is
pinned so yeah White's in a really tough
spot
here it's always nice having basically
more attackers than the opponent has
Defenders though maybe white could try
King H2 or King
H1 simply get the king off the G file
and unpin the G Pawn I'm actually
calculating a pretty beautiful line that
if the king were to move I can show
after the game I was calculating Rook
takes G2 white plays
G4 now the first move I'm looking at is
Bishop takes G4 Pawn takes G4 Rook takes
G4
it seems very close to
Checkmate King H1 Queen H6 there's
Knight
H2 but then I'll have Rook
H4 and that looks like lights out for
white so yeah sacrificing the
bishop again just prioritizing he
activity over material and this is
really just a temporary
sacrifice um it's now a very forcing
line King H1 is only move that doesn't
get
mated and let's play Queen
H6 and Rook
H4 I'm hoping I'm not overlooking
anything like the previous game but uh
yeah I don't see any way for white to
defend the Knight nice having the queen
Rook battery on the H
file but wh King is going to
run um so do I have I have a force
Checkmate here if I take there's King
have three and the king is a little bit
slippery take a
moment I mean taking winds back
material it should definitely start with
this I'm looking at King F3 Queen H5
King
E3 Bishop
C5 King D2 yeah the king will kind of
slip
away
maybe what I can do there's a nice idea
to play Bishop C5
first not directly attacking the king
but optimizing the bishop unleashing the
rook and there's a nice little trick
here that if King
E2 then I have checkmaid in one
move I'll hold off saying what that move
is but uh yeah we'll see if King E2 is
played because it's one of the most like
natural moves for white to try and run
to safety
and with Bishop C5 I'm actually
threatening Queen H5 with Force Nate
because then the king wouldn't have the
E3 Square it would have to move to G3
and then Queen H3 would be
checkmates so it might be Force mate no
matter
what maybe the best try is
D4 try and obstruct the bishop but I
don't think White's going to be
surviving much longer
here okay so we do see King E2
um before I play the Checkmate please
leave a comment below if you spot the
maiden one in this position if you don't
feel free to pause the video or just
feel free to watch and learn Queen
E3 nice unexpected Checkmate taking
advantage of the fact The Rook pins F2
Pawn the King has no squares so uh
pretty nice game hopefully a pretty
instructive game uh shows how to try and
play for a win from pretty early on uh
we had a somewhat symmetrical for
Knights but then things got
asymmetrical especially when I castle
queenside and yeah white actually played
pretty well here with the queenside play
maybe should have looked to play B4 a
bit
sooner um CU yeah Knight C3 perhaps was
a little bit slow and once I play G5 I
think uh yeah the game flowed really
nicely from here and just to show the
line I was calculating if white played
King H2 or King
H1 then I was probably going to sack on
G2 after King takes G2 there's Rook G8
and I think White's just crumbling here
uh Knight G5 doesn't work and if the
king moves I would take threatening the
queen and threatening Rook G2 with some
Force mates so a lot of fun lines that
uh maybe could have happened but game
overall uh let's keep it going we'll do
at least one
more up to
1267 playing young
andyb and we have what do we call this
B3 a Nimo Larson
attack definitely not the most common
opening but uh somewhat of a trendy
opening for some
players and yeah I'm going to play Just
principal chess focus on the center
trying to gain space
early um I didn't play D5 there because
Bishop B5 is sometimes annoying which
would pin the Knight we see Pawn C4
which uh yeah now resembles a reverse
Sicilian and I have a few options
against this move I think the most
principled option is to play Pawn
D5 which basically goes into a reverse
open Sicilian will very likely trade on
D5 and and even though I'm trading a
center Pawn for a wing Pawn or a more um
a less Central Pawn I should say uh this
move does help me gain space and when
white doesn't take on D5 this gives me
some options to gain even more
space and yeah let's uh just take the
space Advantage play Pawn
D4 uh White does have three attackers
against D4 but I have three Defenders
and having the pawn well supported on D4
will hopefully make it a bit more
difficult for white to complete
development uh there's a possible line
that if white were to play Bishop E2
there I would have Pawn D3 and then
Queen E7 check
eventually so white plays Pawn D3 first
I think that's one of the best
moves and now now I have to decide like
how to develop my
Bishops um I could start with Bishop B4
check I could start with Bishop G4 I
don't want to start with Queen E7 which
would just allow white to develop and
block in my own
Bishop so I think Bishop B4 is very
logical comes with Tempo against the
king white pretty much has to block with
a knight here and Knight bd2 most
expected
now yeah I'm trying to figure out if
there's a difference between Bishop G4
Queen E7 or castling I think it's likely
that I'll end up
playing most if not all of these
moves I'm going to start with Bishop
G4 pinning both Knights now yeah Bishop
E2 logical way to break the
pin now I'll briefly calculate takes and
takes and queen E7 but I don't think
it's worth giving up the bishop for that
so let's just go ahead and
castle and white will Castle too most
likely and then yeah then it's a spot
where neither Knight is no longer pinned
white actually has like a decently solid
position
there but I think it's still preferable
for black just having more space in the
center
I mean one alternative for white is
maybe to play
A3 and then try and expand quickly with
B4 there's also a move Knight takes D4
which creates a little bit of
complication because if I take and then
white takes I lose a pawn but then I can
win back the pawn at the very
least um but there could be weird lines
like takes and then takes and then takes
should be somewhere there where black is
for
Choice yeah actually if takes I could
take with Knight and then takes and then
takes and then takes and then Fork on
C2 sometimes with lines like that like
if you're playing white you should just
intuitively realize that there's too
many dangers with taking the pawn on
D4 so opponent tanking a little bit
I'm now up on time yeah I'd say the
three candidate moves for white are A3
castling and
H3 I don't see anything else that makes
too much
sense I completely forgot I made tea
before I started recording I haven't
dren the tea
yet drinking is probably not a word
I haven't drunk the tea
yet until
now okay so we do see
castling and
now yeah I should have been like
thinking further what what do I do after
castling uh there's a move here
which looks a little bit random but I
think I'll play it and then I'll explain
it so the point of A5 is to prevent
white from expanding standing with
eventual B4 at if A3 I can safely put
the bishop on
C5 and basically I'm just clamping down
on the queen side uh it' be very
difficult for white to now get in this
move Pawn
B4 so it's very typical idea in these
structures with uh with controlling more
space in the center I'm just trying to
control more space in all areas and now
Knight E4 so confrontational move
hitting my knight and my Bishop
um yeah I don't think I want to retreat
the bishop I think I'll be happy by
taking the Knight this does allow the
pawn to get to
E4 but then it will give me a pass Pawn
on
D4 and pawn is still very well
supported and I might just play Simple
chess here like the move that comes to
mind is Queen D6
although Queen D7 might not actually be
so simple so I'm realizing there is
Knight takes
D4 and is white winning a pawn because
if I
take if I take with the bishop there's
Bishop takes G4 if I take the bishop on
E2 there's Knight takes
[Music]
E2 yeah actually I have to be really
careful
here it looks like this is a
threat
yeah and queen
D7 it's actually really interesting it
would support the bishop but Knight D4
is still possible because of the Queen
Bishop battery I
think so I mean it's important to have
it in chess is sometimes before you look
at what you want to do you want to look
at what your opponent wants to
do so I me my problems basically stem
from this bishop being
unsupported and one move that comes to
mind here is Pawn
F5 which sometimes can be weakening but
in this case it supports the bishop and
if takes I can take I open the f
file yeah I'm going to play Pawn
F5 was definitely not the first move
that came to mind but I kind of like the
prospect of transforming the position
where if I can open the file then maybe
it can lead to a later attack on the
king
side and yeah whenever you move your F
Pawn like whether or not your Castle you
always have to watch out for the the new
lines opened towards your king but white
can't really exploit the Sagal so it's
not really a
weakness and with Bishop
D3 now I'll have some
choices I mean taking is
possible but then the bishop can
centralize knight E5 comes to mind
Knight E5 looks really
nice cuz the Knight is pinned the bishop
now no longer on E2 and pressuring the
Knight and the
bishop so if light moves back to
[Music]
E2 then I'll have to figure out what to
do I'd want to take the pawn but then my
knight would be
hanging it's actually not so simple if
life plays Bishop
E2 it feels like there should be
something easy with the E4 Pawn
undefended but my knight is also
attacked in that
line so let's try and calculate Bishop
E2 I take and then Bishop takes I still
can't take on e4 and if takes and then
takes not really winning anything we're
just trading in that
line
and Bishop E2 is
played I can't spend too long
here any simple options like maybe I
should start by taking D3 also comes to
mind but that that can't be
good if I take and then Bishop
takes and then maybe F4 yeah I'm not not
entirely sure but
at least this maintains control over the
position it does feel wrong to give away
the bishop
pair but basically the plan is to get a
position where the center is now
actually pretty closed and the Bishops
are not so effective for
White and the D4 Pawn still supported F4
also supported and there's cases where
these pawns could be overextended but
yeah everything is is well supported I
can support everything more if I want
to White plays Queen D2 giving me the
option of taking and doubling the
pawns I'm trying to calculate takes and
then takes and then Rook
A6 and then King
H1 and then Rook H6 and then Rook G1 and
then Queen H4 and then Rook G2 I'm not
quite mating
there
yeah I don't want to take too long on
this move
but
um yeah I'm not sure like it it feels
like a no-brainer to double White's
pawns but then white gets the G file and
if White's in time to play Rook
G2 then maybe the G file can be an asset
for
white so I'm going to start with Rook A6
here which is basically a preparatory
move preparing to take and then lift The
Rook over to H6 or
G6 white plays
B4 now I think I can just ignore the
queen side cuz yeah it seems very very
close
to completely winning on the king
side um but I have to be precise cuz if
I played this then King here and then
Queen here and then Rook here so I don't
think I want to give white
time to save the
king or to to move the king to
H1 if I play Queen H4 first I'm losing
my
Bishop but then I check and then here
and then here I don't see how White's
stopping
checkmates so let's go for Queen
H4 yeah it's nice idea like lifting The
Rook from A8 all the way to H6 uh not
something you see every day but it's
nice having the whole sixth rank
open and this is what we call a rook
lift in
chess also called a
Rover um there might be some other terms
for it
[Music]
too uh now there's a few options I could
start with Rook H6 but then maybe Rook
E1 and the King can slip away so I think
it's nice to provoke King H1 and then
play Rook
H6 and this is what I was calculating
initially
and yeah I don't see any any way to save
the white
king um this is why it was nice to start
with Rook A6 first instead of taking on
F3 because if White had one more move to
play Rook G1 and Rook G2 then um it
wouldn't be so simple but white resigns
there so uh nice kind of attacking game
um yeah I'm getting to the rating level
where my opponents aren't making like
obvious blunders a lot of these games
I've really had to work for my wins and
we're seeing like higher level strategic
middle gamep playay so again hopefully
some lessons to take away um I didn't
want to point out here that there's a a
cute trap that if Bishop E2 then Pawn D3
is really strong forcing Bishop F1 and
then Queen E7 and then there's no way
for white to not lose material cuz any
any blocking move loses a minor
piece so what happened this game um yeah
white actually had a solid
position but eventually just kind of
fell under pressure on the king side
probably should not have allowed Knight
takes F3 in what happened in the game
but yeah this position wasn't so easy
for white because if the bishop
Retreats I'm going to have Pawn F3 to
keep attacking and still witht The Rook
over
so yeah I'm not sure what white should
have done maybe bishop G4 was a better
option to then try and maybe plant the
bishop on D5 or put the bishop on H3 and
try and get an
F3 but uh yeah anyway nice game I think
I will wrap it up there so thanks
everyone for watching if you have
questions leave them below look forward
to reading the comments if you like this
content be sure to subscribe a lot of
episodes coming in the future so stay
tuned for next one and I'll see you guys
soon